بالامس كان هناك قلق في اسرائيل من مجريات
المجريات امام محكمه العدل الدوليه هل ما
زال القلق يعتري الاوساط الاسرائيليه بعد
الدفوع التي قدمها الفريق القانوني
الاسرائيلي اليوم
باعتقادك مساء الخير نعم القلق ما زال
موجودا والدليل على ذلك كيفيه تفاعل
الاوساط الاسرائيليه المختلفه مع ما جرى
سواء بالامس او اليوم يعني ما جرى بالامس
كانت هناك رد فعل انفعاليه من قبل القياده
الاسرائيليه كان اشبه بالجنون في كيفيه
التفاعل مع هذه القضيه مخاصمه المحكمه
والحديث بشكل عدواني تجاه جنوب افريقيا
والهيئه القضائيه الان انتقلوا الى مستوى
اخر من من الحديث وهو ينطلق من يعني عدم
اليقين بان الدفوع التي قدمت من قبل ال
الدفاع الاسرائيلي قادره على مواجهه كل ما
تم تقديمه من دلائل وبراهين من قبل جنوب
افريق افريقيا بالاضافه الى ذلك هم
يستشعروا ان هناك خطوره قد تمت او خسائر
قد تمت بمجرد عرض القضيه امام المحكمه
يعني المساله ليست مرتبطه بما هييه
القرارات التي يمكن ان تصدر فحسب وانما هم
يتفاعلوا مع القضيه على ان المساله فعلا
قد حققت خساره كبيره لاسرائيل ولذلك نرى
ان التفاعل في اسرائيل يتم الان على شكلين
الاول وهو يعني نوع من انواع الوحده
الوهميه ما بين الكثير من الاطراف
السياسيه الاسرائيليه التي تتحدث ب لسان
واحد لترفض كل ما تم تقديمه من جنوب
افريقيا لانهم يستشعروا بانه الكيان
المعنوي لاسرائيل مهدد بمعنى ان الحصانه
التي تمتعت بها على المستوى الدولي
وتحديدا على المستوى الغربي على مدار عقود
طويله من النقد الان تنهار ووصلوا وتجاوز
الامر مستوى النقد الى مستوى محاوله
الادانه تغذت يعني هذه الحصانه
الاسرائيليه على مسالتين الاولى استدعاء
دائما التاريخ اليهودي والهولوكوست
وبالتالي اي حديث دائما يربط ب هذا
الموضوع على انهم ضحايا والمساله الثانيه
الاستقواء بمفهوم معادات الساميه وهذا
الامر كسر في في المحكمه بالامس وهذا ما
يشعرهم بتخوف كبير جدا على المدى
الاستراتيجي والبعيد وليس بالضروره على
المدى الاني وامام
القلق والغضب كما ذكرت تجاه ما قدمته جنوب
افريقيا امام المحكمه من ادله وبراهين على
الاتهام بان اسرائيل ترتكب اباده جماعيه
كيف بدا الرضا في داخل اسرائيل على
الاستراتيجيه المتبعه من الفريق القانوني
الذي يمثل اسرائيل في داخل
المحكمه يعني يبدو انه بدا تسييس حتى ردود
الافعال على ما قدم من
قبل الاسرائيليين ك دفوع ضد ما قدم من
جنوب افريقيا بمعنى انه من يتابع الان
المشهد الاسرائيلي وكيفيه تفاعل النخبه
الاسرائيليه ال وفي نهايه المطاف هي نخبه
محسوبه على القيادات السياسيه وعلى
الاحزاب السياسيه هناك تباين جزء من
الكتابات الاسرائيليه ذ ذهبت باتجاه انه
هناك محاوله لطمانه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وان ربما يعني تذهب المحكمه الى تخفيف
القرار يعني لا يتحدث عن تبريء اسرائيل
الان وانما يتحدث عن ان القرار الصادر
ربما لا يكون قاسيا تجاه اسرائيل المساله
الثانيه وبرايي هي الاهم ان هناك الكثير
من الكتابات التي بدات تتحدث عن محاسبه
المسؤولين الذين اوصلوا اسرائيل الى هذا
الموقع ان تجد نفسها تحاكم الان وهذا
برايي هو المساله الاهم لانه يزيد من
تعميق الخلافات الاسرائيليه كنت اشرت في
مداخلتي الاولى ان هناك حاله وحده وهميه
الان من حيث الخطاب تجاه الخارج لكن من
حيث الداخل هناك محاوله لتحميل المسؤوليه
لاطراف بعينها وتحديدا للائتلاف الحاكم
بقياده بنيامين نتنياهو شهدنا محاولات
الان ايضا من قبل الكثير من الاطراف
الاسرائيليه ل للجم
ال القيادات الاسرائيليه التي تتحدث
بطريقه غير غير دبلوماسيه مع العالم وهذا
برايي يكشف ايضا حاله الزيف داخل اسرائيل
التي يشار الى ان هناك نوع من التنوع داخل
اسرائيل حقيقه هناك خلافات اسرائيليه لكن
ما يجري حقيقه ان اسرائيل متفقه الان على
الحرب متفقه على ما يجري داخل قطاع غزه
لكنهم مختلفون الان في كيفيه تقديم ذلك
للراي العام ولاطفال المستوى الدولي لذلك
ان ان صب الان النقد في اسرائيل ليس على
الفعل وانما على كيفيه التعبير عن هذا
الموضوع المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه بدات تتحدث عن امكانيه
التحقيق مع مسؤولين اسرائيليين في كيفيه
التفاعل مع هذه القضيه لكن الانتقادات
الان باتت تصل الى انه راس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هو المسؤول الاساسي لانه لم
يتخذ خطوات بالحرف الواحد قيل في دعوه
احرنوت لم يضرب على الطاوله امام مجلس
الوزراء حين تفوه الكثير من الوزراء بامور
ها هي الان تستخدم كدليل ضد اسرائيل